se você for falar eu acho que o o que eu
geralmente utilizo hoje e que inclusive
existe em bula até o um uso para
anticoagulação preventiva é o
picnogenol tá a gente fala da síndrome
do Viajante Então hoje se usa o piquin
genol de uma maneira antes e depois de
uma viagem para prevenção de de trombose
para pacientes o piqu inogen ele tem uma
ação muito importante o quê na drenagem
linfática então ele vai ajudar muito
tanto As veias que não estão incluídas
quanto o sistema linfático a não deixar
essa perna entrar no estado de
emergência de inchaço de dor de
escurecimento então a associação do
piquin ginal com o anticoagulante
farmacológico é muito elegante porque
vai otimizar a ação desse anticoagulante
e ao mesmo tempo vai Minimizar os riscos
que essa perna fique enchada com varizes
escura e com dor